the big story we have right now because
obviously many people have been
following mike lindell's cyber symposium
we have a development in the dominion
mike lindell saga which i find to be
quite interesting we have a story from
business insider a federal judge denied
motions from sydney powell rudy giuliani
and mike lindell to dismiss dominion's
lawsuits against them it's from just
about an hour ago and as many of you may
be knowing mike lindell's cyber
symposium is currently ongoing where
they are having they have a bunch of
speakers a bunch of experts mike
lindell's offered five million dollars
to anyone who can prove that his data
isn't the actual voter data and they're
going through screenshots they've got
hash data and stuff i got to be honest
one of the most challenging things for a
regular person
is trying to understand what it is
they're presenting because it's a lot of
it is you'll see ip addresses you'll see
networking details you'll see hash codes
and you're going to be like i don't know
what those things mean and that can be
well in my opinion it can probably lead
people to make false assumptions so look
they're they're still doing their
symposium i'll let mike lindell do a
symposium like i'm not gonna i won't
make judgments i will wait and see but i
gotta be honest
i am not confident at all and i'll tell
you why a federal judge denied motions
from sydney power rudy giuliani and mike
lindell to dismiss okay well hold on a
minute back when dominion announced they
were suing mike lindell he actually came
out and said he was quote very happy to
hear that dominion had sued him quote
now i can get to the evidence faster
it's going to be amazing he said yet
that he plans to continue releasing more
movies more documentaries about alleged
election fraud my issue there is if he
was really happy
that he was being sued because that
would give him the ability to enter
discovery against dominion
why would he try to dismiss that lawsuit
so look
i i think i i favor the audits i favor
uh bolstering confidence in our election
systems and the mainstream media says
that everything mike lindell is doing is
not doing that but the problem is you
already have people who don't have
confidence in it so i think in order to
restore confidence you need to give
people the investigations you need to
say look when you're subpoenaed here's
the data and just go through the motions
because this country is horribly
horribly divided
but i got to say in this story uh you
know as you as you probably guys uh you
know from the intros that that sheamus
tried doing
that i did do until you stole it from me
we're watching cast will's a lawyer and
uh uh you brought up some statements
from the judge i don't know if you
wanted to to read them yeah let me let
me pull up the things
i did i did tweet them out um so yeah
the ju i mean actually i think it so the
judge issued these uh statements and
what you have yeah no i pulled it up um
so this is you know portions of the
motion to dismiss the ruling on the
motion to dismiss it's like a 35-page
ruling
um
but this is making fun of one of the
experts that uh powell and lindell were
relying on in their in their lawsuit to
explain why like they were justified in
bringing this that they they were being
authentic etc
um they said that this expert has quote
been ordered to pay more than 25 000
after finding that the expert violated
consumer protection laws by misspending
money she raised
and then the judge goes on to say quote
that expert has also publicly claimed
that george soros president george w h
bush's father the muslim brotherhood and
leftists helped form the deep state in
nazi germany in the 1930s which would
have been a remarkable feat for soros
who was born in 1930.
um
look it may seem like oh that's like
whatever a cute joke federal judges
don't tell jokes in their opinions and
if they're telling jokes that you are
the butt of that's like terrible you're
you that's not good
um there's another
instance where uh let's see if i can
find the next particular nasty quote but
isn't it isn't it bad for a judge to be
joking in this way and and making you
know what i mean it's weird but it's
also kind of the nature of the arguments
that he would inevitably be saying some
things that are kind of ridiculous so
basically a defamation claim you have to
prove actual malice right that's one of
the things you have to prove under new
york times versus sullivan that someone
either knowingly lied or showed a
reckless disregard for the truth i think
we're actually all pretty familiar with
that now because defamation comes up a
lot oh yeah in
modern internet culture
so
in order one of the way that dominion
one of the ways the dominion is alleging
actual malice on the part of paul
lindell is is they're saying no
reasonable person could believe these
things so assuming they are reasonable
they're re they're clearly reckless in
making these statements like their
statements are so outlandish that you
have to be reckless to me i i do take
issue with that though
i mean sometimes crazy things turn out
to be
true you know what i mean that's why my
attitude on this is like look
if somebody comes out and they're like
i'm gonna spend millions of dollars on a
cyber symposium and hire all these
people and offer a five million dollars
i'm like all right
i mean if he loses five million dollars
well then he put up five million dollars
and he lost it you know but like here's
the point from dominion i mean obviously
it shouldn't be criminal right like
where you know this is the free country
um but we still have definition losses
oh no right right
i'm just saying in terms of like the the
general uh uh environment when it comes
to you know the media's approach or the
judge saying no reasonable person could
believe these things i think the judge
should be like
present your evidence now here's the
problem mike lindell had an opportunity
with this lawsuit to present evidence
proving that his statements were in fact
true therefore it was not defamation
instead tried to get it dismissed well i
mean i think he did also one of his own
arguments was also that what i said was
true and he now will get that
opportunity like he we're going to
discovery like he'll be deposed uh and
there'll be immense amounts of discovery
on both sides right certainly lindell
will be able to go to dominion and try
and get information out of them that
proves lindell's claims but dominion
will be able to go lindell and and
demand his factual basis and every bit
of his facts for saying otherwise i've
read a lot about the uh
allegations the anomalies the states
admittedly i think there's some some
things that should be investigated
absolutely there's a video of a woman
and she puts the ballot in multiple
times but the problem is that in and of
itself isn't enough evidence to prove
anything but i do think it's like okay
we'll do an audit i i think that's
that's fair if you've got half the
country and half the country put it
against each other to the point where
there's violence in the streets it's
like let's just calm down and sort this
thing through and it if you're confident
that everything was was perfect and the
most secure as i think the dhs said then
let's
give the people the opportunity to feel
confident and secure in this agreed
election integrity should be like
caesar's wife right beyond reproach uh i
mean in israel
there are so many different measures
like you are videotaped going into a
voting booth you're there's like you put
your fingerprint on it i mean there's so
many different things that mean that you
physically have to show up absentee
ballots are just favored etc say the
line in
graphene dmt wait where are we going no
read the code free the code this is
exactly what i'm thinking
now this is a little bit different than
what we're talking about the lindell
situation but the fact that they're
tallying votes in private with
proprietary software code i believe is
the scandal that's that's i i agree and
that actually lends itself back to the
defamation suit which is really
interesting because
dominion was damaged by this yeah
substantially because i'm telling you
right now i don't care uh um
in regards to moving forward with our
elections okay obviously i care if there
was impropriety personally i think a lot
of people are incorrect in their
assumptions about what happened and i
think
i keep hearing these things like oh
march 3rd march 5th march 11th oh april
4th like they keep saying people still
believe that trump is going to be
reinstated i'm like guys
i we had bannon on the show bannon said
he believes a lot of the stuff i pushed
back i don't i think that we we saw the
article from time magazine we saw voting
in the park we saw the republicans in
pennsylvania change the violate the
constitution at least according to a
lower court judge for universal mail-in
voting you've got california now people
are pointing out is going to allow you
to print ballots at home i think people
need to realize voter integrity is is
the big issue now certainly i'm all for
investigations whatever but when it
comes to dominion what i'm seeing
looking to the future you know i look
forward to seeing whatever it is the
experts and the symposium end up with
but you know i digress in the future we
can't use dominion and it's not even
about the allegations
what mike lindell has done is brought to
the forefront a very serious issue not
even my i i think mike lindell
absolutely with with his claims
and and and feel free to say the dudes
out of his mind we now have to to answer
one question why
is why are we using proprietary unseen
software code in our public elections
i i just i can't accept that and if it
wasn't for the the this news cycle
michael and alan and and the supposing
model stuff we wouldn't even be talking
about the fact that we have a company
with with proprietary
proprietary code that we can't actually
see right well that's if that's all that
was causing dominion's damages actually
lindell and powell and whoever would be
in much better shape because they would
be able to say that it's actually
truthful claims right that would have
that would have caused the damages the
problem here is that what's alleged in
the uh you know in the complaint i mean
and i don't know exactly the extent of
what lindell said but i don't think that
they would i don't think that dominion's
lawyers would go out there and falsify
quotations from lindell i think they
could go into the record and find them
it's the kind of thing you'd get caught
on and really
slap down for professional ethics so
you know when mike lindell released some
uh
like like hash code data
and then the media came out and said you
know i think with cnn they were like we
had 30 experts or like 15 experts look
at this we said it was nothing
the reality is even before cnn did it i
actually hit up one of my hacker buddies
and asked them what they thought of it
and they were like i don't we don't see
anything here like it's it's it's it's
like it's data it doesn't it's not
proving anything happened and then mike
lindell came out said oh that's not
that's just to show we have the data and
so for me it's kind of been really
difficult to to track now for what are
we going on we're going on almost a year
of all the claims and accusations that
keep changing that keep evolving i i'll
admit i think there are things that were
anomalous that definitely give me pause
that we should look into
but i've just been sitting here waiting
like with every guest we've had on the
show talking about this and i won't call
every single person but even people like
bannon i'm just like please show me
something anything and it's always like
well there's an anomaly here and i'm
like i get that but saying like a man
walked through a dark alley at midnight
doesn't prove he robbed the bank you
know what i mean
yeah there's like a lot of
it feels very like kind of there's a lot
of obfuscating going on like they're
trying to like and then also extrapolate
you know why you know aggressive
extrapolation um and i mean i'm speaking
to somebody who again i recorded the
video the poll watcher being kicked out
of philadelphia of a polling station in
philadelphia that went viral on election
day like i mean you're not you're not
talking to a person who thinks these
elections are pristine or that there's
some there aren't some serious problems
but this the stuff that they've been
saying i mean i remember you know when
city powell originally alleged stuff
like venezuela and russia cooperated to
regular elections remember the the
german servers and the shootout with the
cia in germany or whatever it's just
like come on
i didn't remember any of that yeah can
you lay out some of the specific claims
they've made that seem i mean i i don't
want to like
i don't have it in front of me so i have
to remember it but there was a press
conference where it was and it was like
the trump campaign press conference with
uh giuliani jenna ellis
uh and sydney powell i think and maybe
one or two other people but i know
sydney those three spoke and sydney was
the one who just out of nowhere started
making allegations about
the foreign actors colluding to like rig
the election
and i remember thinking the time was i
was like well that's an aggressive claim
i wonder what she's got to back that up
and it turned out we haven't seen
anything substantive to back that up
there's
weird business connections weird
international individuals and business
people and all that stuff but the
challenge is and i think this is
important for any for the people who
genuinely believe all of these claims
and and think trump is going to be
orientated you go to a regular person
who doesn't pay attention to the news
and you tell them these things and
they're going to walk out the door in
two seconds well and also this
reinstatement thing i mean the
reinstatement claim like even if
everything powell and trump and lindell
are saying is true
that doesn't lead to trump being
reinstated right because there's a
process the only way you know to remove
a president in turn you have to impeach
him the vice president takes power are
you going to then impeach the vice
president i guess their plan is to have
trump run for house and then hopefully
make him speaker of the house and then
somehow get him in the line of
succession but not on august or the
future you know dominoes of impeachment
to fall but like yeah that's that's you
know a year and a half from now he's you
know do we need is there going to be a
congressman who dies and then trump is
appointed as like a special election
then he becomes speaker even though we
don't have a majority
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time